>> Hi,YouTubers, my name is Trevor Manuel.
I am the Minister responsible for planning
in the Republic of South
Africa.
It's a great opportunity to be sharing with
you here from Davos, that
we're able to engage with you and pick up
on the issues that matter to
you.
Today, the world is in very powerless state
at the moment, coming out
of the recession caused largely by excesses
in the financial sector.
A lot of the emphasis has been placed on the
balance sheets of banks,
size of the deficit of government.
But the bigger challenges lie in the impact
of the financial crisis on
the lives of very ordinary working people,
people who have lost their
jobs, people who've lost access to credit,
to the houses, to all manner
of issues. A major setback in the lives of
the poor.
So as we deal with issues right now we must
focus.